[Musica]
se vuoi che ti guardi mi dispiace ma ciò
l'insalata è bello e tutti ragazzi
prevenuti avessero video sono fa vj oggi
siamo tornati su emily walls to play fa
sempre rimasta frase però non ha senso
per il fatto che tanto viene buio mica
neanche il mago otelma
volevo dirvi ragazzi prima di partire in
questo gameplay molto serio volevo dirvi
due cose allora la prima è che sto
crepando di caldo che sta merda procedi
i capelli che fanno veramente schifo
grazie per la porta allo stesso tempo
ragazzi ordinato un'insalata da internet
quindi devo riuscire a finire l'episodio
di ieri di workshop la prima che mi
arrivi in insalata eravamo rimasti che
dovevo praticamente trovare la tizia ci
fosse una volta nella vita che riesca a
trovare st [ __ ] il primo corpo è
una cosa incredibile è finito anche il
tempo niente ragazzi non l'ho trovata
michela partenza da dio perfetto
magari si chiude la porta non arriva dal
tipo di motta non posso dire la fa stavo
scherzando
sto passando la mia vita su sta roba e
non è una cosa che non va bene me l'ha
detto anche il medico dovrei smettere
però ancora sta cosa non l'ho capita in
verità prove o salve non era la tazza
del cesso elice lista pisciando sul muro
l'essere umano ha inventato questa cosa
chiamata accesso che può usare l'ultima
novità ad andare avanti dietro cercarla
st bambino soggiorno che non si è tratto
mi avete detto che c'è una scatola che
si apre dopo ecco la no questa invece si
chiama porta dell'armadio perché si
muove se mi giro io ho le piace mostrare
il culo a sia equa mi distraggono non va
bene non ho capito il perché vabbè mica
andata ma il problema non è ancora lì
allora ho capito che ci ha avuto
un'infanzia difficile che non hai
giocato a nascondino
ma non si gioca così cioè dovresti
andare a nascondersi in un altro posto
se ti ho trovata qui nemiche pace
ragazzine che ben può non essere capace
a fare le cose non è capace
brava e basta un attimo e capisci subito
non è stupido nel mondo cazzo sta sarà
qua dentro per forza è infatti sta cosa
qua non la capiscono equa dei saggi sono
la vetro fini scommettete che adesso non
la trovo più ragazzi manco a pagarla c'è
di nuovo non so perché questa cosa ma la
cosa non la capisco
stavo scherzando non mi prendete sul
serio e sono stupido ma è arrivata al
meritato l'insalata proprio adesso deve
arrivare insalata di mortacci sua un
attimo un attimo che cazzo successo vi
ho vinto ma serio 9 ragazza cosa guarda
dentro con voi perché non ho visto cosa
è successo e quindi che cosa è successo
porca [ __ ] 90 90 secondi devo trovare
della bambina posso andare di software
ed io non posso andar lì stavo
scherzando stavo scafati
al 13 buona
casio chiarisce anche tu e lì sono
attacchi la gente a sentire dobbiamo
giocare aa.vv 7 gioca con mio cugino che
c'ha tre anni non ho scassà o cazz enti
zia ci stiamo prendendo per il culo ma
perché c'è il contatore o ma [ __ ]
sentirà che possono statua vita devo
trovare la bambina perché se non scade
il tempo ciò nel culo capito ciao frate
ci sei anche tu non sapevo che bella
sorpresa anche la bambina perfetto dove
devo trovare non è impossibile che non
posso trovare
qualcuno di voi ha voglia di spiegarmi
come io potrei trovare la tipa che si
nasconde se ci sono anche se milioni
come è possibile hanno aumentato pure il
tempo come per dire la rete la mettiamo
facile ma facile sto cazzo ci sono anche
gli altri o ecco la starda di merda ce
l'ho fatta che non ci credo niente non
riescono anche rapirle corte pensate
cazzo have a pezzi o dietro le scatole
madonna neanche io da bambino facevo ste
cagate ciò nel culo che non nel culo
aiuta aiuta [ __ ] eh vabbè rea non
c'è ma dove
[Musica]
se vuoi che ti guardi mi dispiace ma ciò
l'insalata cazzo vuoi che faccia ha
fatto il giro anche se ha deciso di non
toccarmi all'inizio ma la bailar l'adam
base necessito nabu e cade una piega ma
può saperlo alla fine no vabbè comunque
dall'ati palo vista stanley quindi io
aspetterò i prossimi 75 secondi
trastullando la minchia di re tanto so
dove giochiamo tutti quanti trovami
questo c'è scritto grazie per la dritta
ti potresti togliere al cazzo che passa
al passano i secondi rischio di morire
un altro chiedo a ritogliere [ __ ]
grazie perché ha smesso no no anzi
massima lo so che sei una [ __ ] anzi ma
brava bravissima raga quanto deve
esistere
porca [ __ ] ti io mio come mi sono
salvata non avete idea del culo hai
smesso gli assi mare perché ti ho dato
della [ __ ] ma non devi farti
condizionare dagli altri a zia devi
essere quello che vuoi essere dove cazzo
è l'altra ma una ecco la cosa più che
bella ma che te devo dì zia 6 pali da un
cadavere mangiare un po di frutta fai
come fare
mangia l'insalata abbiamo capito che la
tipa decide lei quando comparirebbe tipo
adesso
[ __ ]
[Musica]
se non vinco adesso che morisse la
famiglia de possino piglia in trainer
gumer in faccia che cazzo ci fa un
tavolo per terra che già è difficile sto
gioco ho acceso la luce sono un idiota
ho acceso la luce non [ __ ] idiota ma
c'é solo lui ma vabbè non lo so a babbo
natale lo avete invitato chiedo è
c'è ma veramente quanto culo quanto da
12 miliardi ha smesso di respirare ma
perché non lo capisco sta cosa cosa
all'improvviso le sta sul culo respirare
non capisco più brutto così perché
veramente non sento nulla mi sento
osservati simo ma ragazza fissati
fastidio cosa succede cos'è sta su tutti
oggi vistare che devi stare calmo frate
devi stare calmo veramente insegnate la
giocare a nascondino perchè giuro non
veramente ha mai capito
sta qui non ha capito tu hai capito come
si gioca lei no questo organismo che
stai facendo lo fa anche tua madre non
lo chiedo
vabbè stanno passando troppo capitana
quanta di quanta gente se successo te ne
vai
oddio minchia aspettavo un attimo ancora
ero morto no no no no no no no che buso
del cumulo di per sé ma è le guardi il
culetto pure tu e birbantello la porta
dietro si è chiusa grazie
c'è solo un posto dove può essere solo 1
pp per il culo manca solo quello guarda
l'unico posto dove può essere qua dentro
perché saranno almeno alta ed allora
dov'è
vedete che a volte non compare non è
comparsa a volte ragazzi non compare
cosa devo fare quando non compare me la
invento non era seriamente perché non so
cosa fare
che cosa vuol fare quando non c'è più
cosa devo fare un serio
anno al tipo europeo certo è finito
tempo ragazzi proprio l'ultima volta
perché veramente non dovrà andare a
finire la mia insalata prima o poi luci
credevate ma arriva dall insalata
sono le dieci e mezzo non ancora cenato
perché clip stalinista nata da troppo
cresce l'albero cresce sull'insalata no
perché se sto giocando sto gioco da una
vita e mezza e perché non si può finire
cioè la patente per fluttuare zia penso
che se ciao
devo andare devo passare di lì ho capito
che sono snello e posso passare facci
però se è vicinissima paura che mi salta
in faccia quindi magari 7 togli perfetto
perfetto 60 secondi sono buoni timori
sele fratello timori se il fratello chi
fa i cazzi tuoi nella vita una volta per
cortesia davanti alle porte proprio che
non posso uscire pop costa gonna la
gonna nera 12 anni a gomma nera brava
brava brava
[ __ ] gioco di merda che ora direi che
suoli io ci ho provato tutte le maniere
esistenti possibili però a meno che non
mi esca da un nomi cresca la quercia
dall'insalata è meglio che amava anni
l'unica cosa che non capisco è perché
alle volte la tipa non compare adesso
non sono riuscito a dimostrarlo perché
quando tentò di dimostrare una cosa come
facevo con mia madre non riesco mai
della serie mamma quella che non c'è la
maglietta nell'armadio come cazzo è
arriva lei apre l'armadio e la trova
stessa cosa con voi non riuscite a
dimostrarvi che in realtà a volte non
compare la tipa a lui la quercia gli è
cresciuta avanza direttamente perché poi
in questa dovrebbe essere l'ultima notte
quindi spero di concludere nel prossimo
episodio ha senso se vi è piaciuta
sull'argomento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e condiviso il
fratello schizzano city scrive ci
vediamo al prossimo video belle ragazze